been looking forward to this all week
another day at the edinburgh tv festival
today where eastenders actor and
strictly star and winner rose ailing
ellis will be giving the alternative
mctaggart lecture about having a
disability within the industry
rose is with us now she's with her
signer donna as well hello to you uh
rose it's so lovely to see you thank you
for taking the time to join us how has
life changed for you since strictly
yeah it definitely has changed a lot i
definitely don't recognize more but
funnily enough i don't get recognized
for what i look like if when i talk
really loudly i don't recognize
certainly strictly changed the course of
your career
um how how difficult was it for you
um as a
as a deaf actress before you got the
part in eastenders
yeah definitely um i always knew it
going to be a challenge it's going to be
difficult i knew that whatever careers i
would have it will be difficult so
i actually i'm recently i found my old
diaries that i written when i was 16 and
i wrote that i would love to be in tv i
would love to do bbc's tv series but
because i'm deaf it's going to be really
hard so i knew at 16 it going to be hard
tell us tell us about your experiences
growing up
as a deaf child how did you learn to
navigate the world around you
right um i think you don't really have a
choice you have to navigate the world
that you live in um
so
i learned a lot as i grow up a lot of
challenge i have a hearing family so i
learned a lot from them as well and
definitely giving me a lot of tools to
communicate with hearing people
what advice do you offer to young deaf
people who feel that they're overwhelmed
by the world
what advice are we give it to them
i think really they have to find their
own deaf identity and
whatever identities it is no one can
tell them
what it should and shouldn't be
if they want to speak only if they want
to stand only if i want to know both
it's up to that person no one can tell
them what to do
it's a big deal it's a huge deal giving
the alternative mctaggett lecture
how do you feel about being asked
and
what do you want to say as part of it
so
it is so previous to be asked to do this
lecture
it is such a big honor because that's
the voice that i can use to make people
listen
um
i'm definitely quite nervous about it of
course um but i think it's not telling
people up it's more of
being honest and telling my experience
and hopefully people can
think about it and listen and think
about what they can do to improve for
deaf and disabled pastors
in front of a screen and behind the
camera
yeah now many of our viewers will know
that you launched um a deaf barbie doll
recently tell us about
that i really enjoyed it it's quite fun
to dress up like a barbie and have a
whole barbie but
it is such a such a big moment is to
have a barbie that looks like the people
and
the world because that's how our world
is the world is full of people who are
different there's no same people so it's
nice to have a barbie to represent that
and we're just looking at that as we're
chatting to you rose um
uh if i asked you what was your most
memorable moment on strictly i wonder if
you might say this let's just have a
look at this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the moment that you won everybody's
hearts here in the uk and across the
world how do you remember it
yeah really i'm just trying so hard to
remember my stats and not messed up and
i was trying to remember my routine so
much so i think um
i knew it was going to be a big moment
but i didn't think it was spread out
that much that wow
wow
it was definitely
yeah um
that was then what's next what have you
got planned for next
what what snack
recipe
uh because i'm hearing
on the grapevine
that you might be doctor who's new
assistant
i have no idea where that got started it
was very much just spread faster oh okay
that sounds like a really great job
so there's no truth in that rumor as far
as you're concerned are you just being a
little bit coy with my viewers this
morning
no no there's no food there's no truth
it's just i think it was a rumor that
started last week on twitter and i
thought oh and then it just got bigger
and bigger now it's everywhere i'm like
oh
well we hope that you are and we think
that you would be a sensational
assistant to doctor who uh we do
appreciate you taking the time to join
us this morning
thanks very much indeed for joining us
bye bye
thank you thank you for interviewing me